gráfica la siguiente ecuación es igual a
menos 5 x al cuadrado más 50 x menos 120
vámonos a un lugar donde puede escribir
bien tenía hallar la ecuación que es
igual a menos 5 x al cuadrado más 50 x
menos 120
y esta ecuación me determina una
parábola como el coeficiente de la x al
cuadrado es negativo yo sé que es una
parábola que abre hacia abajo en otras
palabras mi parábola se ve algo así
también x
y por acá es también
y yo sé que mi parábola hace algo como
esto
no es la parábola más bonita que he
trazado pero servirá ok el modo en el
que voy a encontrar la gráfica es
buscando las raíces de esta ecuación las
intersecciones con el eje x dos puntos
donde ya vale cero y buscando el vértice
que es precisamente el punto cuya
coordenada x está justo a la mitad de
las intersecciones de la parábola con el
eje x entonces antes que nada lo que voy
a observar es que si igualó esta
ecuación a cero para encontrar las
raíces o las intersecciones con el eje x
entonces esto se convierte en cero es
igual a menos 5 x al cuadrado más 50 x
menos 120 ahora bien esta ecuación
cuadrática la podría resolver por
ejemplo mediante la fórmula cuadrática
pero en vez de eso voy a tratar de
factorizar este polinomio para
facilitarme la vida voy a dividir todo
entre menos 5 voy a vivir aquí entre
menos 5 y aquí entre menos 5 y aquí
entre menos 5
aquí entre -5 entonces bien 0 entre -5
es igual a 0 menos 5 entre menos cinco
es uno por lo que me queda x al cuadrado
50 entre menos cinco es menos 10 menos
10 x y menos 120 entre menos cinco es 24
positivo así que resolver esta ecuación
la que esté naranja equivale resolver
esta que está en morado
bien entonces lo que quiero buscar o lo
que quiero encontrar son dos números
cuyo producto sea 24 positivo y cuya
suma sea menos 10
estos dos números son los puede
encontrar por inspección menos seis y
menos cuatro menos seis por menos cuatro
me da 24 positivo y menos seis menos
cuatro menos seis más menos cuatro me da
menos diez así que este polinomio se
factoría como
x menos 4 por x menos 6 estos son los
factores de este polinomio y esto cuando
se hace cero para que este número valga
0 o este caso o en este caso tienen que
valer cero por lo tanto x vale 4
x vale 6 esas son las dos raíces que
tiene mi polinomio de modo que estos
puntos tienen coordenadas de color
este punto aquí sería el punto 4 punto
cero
y este punto acá es el punto 60 y como
les decía el vértice tiene coordenadas
que son precisamente la mitad de las
coordenadas x de estos dos raíces así
que este punto tiene coordenada x el
punto que está entre 4 y 6 sería el
punto 5 y para el valor de 5 qué valor
tome esta expresión pues si yo sustituyó
aquí por 5 podría escribirlo así y de 5
cuanto vale esta función si sustituye o
x igual a 5 pues vale menos 5 por 5 al
cuadrado más 50 por 5 menos 120
y eso cuánto es 5 al cuadrados 25 x
menos 5 es menos 125
más 50 por 5 50 por 5 es 250 menos 120
de modo que tengo 120 perdón
100 menos 125 menos 120 sería menos 245
250 sería 5 entonces este punto es el 55
vamos a checar nuestro trabajo bien mi
primera intersección con el eje x se
daba en x igual a 6
mi segunda intersección con el eje x se
daba en
el vértice de la parábola estaba
precisamente en el punto 55 así que
chequemos ya estamos en lo correcto